yes sir whenever I read news like that I get
so don't gand excited that I say what's the
matter don't news like that mean nothin to you
fellas means a whole lot to me yeah and I'm a
Texaco dealer just like the rest of you fellas
of course maybe I say young and good-looking
is that buckaroo and the fifth role there and
maybe i-it's a prosperous lookin there's that
gent in the brown suit over on the left yeah
it's you I mean mister I'm doing all right
doing better and better every year with all this
defense money being spent this year ought to be
the best of all now this paper says that the
national income went up four billion dollars
last year and they expect it to go even higher
this year somebody's calculated that the average
family income is going to be 280 to 300 dollars
more this year than last and boy that ain't hey
maybe you think the same as I did it first maybe
just don't seem reasonable that there could be
200 to $300 more for each working man coming into
your town and mine but shucks and he'd necessary
but maybe he takes only a few thousand dollars
more coming into town because it gets to be more
income for different people passing around from
hand to hand I'll take mr. Richards a customer
of mine he's just been made superintendent down
one of the plants he's got some extra money and
he calls in Joe Mullins the carpenter to fix the
back steps that his wife's been complaining about
for months Joe oh he gets some extra money from
working steady and some overtime for people like
the Richards and he goes to George Moffatt found
a hardware store for some new tools we got Lorne
one Cocker in town so George Moffatt good sells
a lot more tools and things he makes enough more
out of his store so that he turns in his car gets
himself a new one did we land themselves in that
car he spends the commission he gets down to the
reliable store for some new shirts and some toys
for his kids and did Waylon he he sold George
Muppet his new car because he got there first
and his company is way out in front advertising
their car and all the magazines and billboards
all around town the speaking of advertising you
know fellas I was over chewing the fat with Ned
Billings who's got a place right to opposite my
station it was on Friday and seemed to me that we
is interrupted about every two minutes by somebody
coming in and putting down a dime and taking up a
copy of life well it got to be annoying you know
business interfering with pleasure that way so
I said today they said sir city Ned you got to
sell that whole pile of magazines before we can
get a word in together and then it got to tell me
that that happens almost every day in the week he
starts out the day with a great big pile of
magazines on Tuesdays it's Saturday evening
posts on other days it's Colliers and Time and
Newsweek can like a great big stack like that
of each of these weekly and I remembered how every
morning our mailman cusses about the load he's got
to carry calls this the reading this town always
complaining about all the magazine's he's got to
deliver every day and I got to thinking about lads
like little Johnny Myers next door who's always
selling and delivering magazines shows you learn a
baseball batter a pair of roller skates come down